ON, IS GOING TO TELL US WHY IT’S
NOW OR NEVER FOR THE AMERICAN
RECOVERY.
BUT FIRST, MY THOUGHTS ON
AMERICA IN SHUTDOWN DAY 50.
50.
HARD TO BELIEVE.
AFTER CHINA’S LIES AND DECEIT
ABOUT THE CORONAVIRUS, THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC I THINK IS
FINALLY BEGINNING TO GET IT.
THEY ARE SEEING THE COMMUNIST
NATION FOR WHAT IT IS: AN ENEMY
OF THE UNITED STATES AND OF FREE
PEOPLE EVERYWHERE.
A PEW RESEARCH POLL LAST MONTH
SHOWS THAT TWO-THIRDS OF
AMERICANS NOW HAVE AN
UNFAVORABLE VIEW OF CHINA.
AN RNC SURVEY SHOWED SIMILARLY
NEGATIVE VIEWS ON CHINA AMONG
VOTERS IN SEVERAL KEY
BATTLEGROUND STATES.
NOW, LONG BEFORE THIS FIRST CASE
OF COVID-19 SHOWED UP IN SEATTLE
SEATTLE, CHINA HAD CO-OPTED THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION, WE’VE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT THAT
RECENTLY.
JUST AS THEY’VE DONE, BY THE
WAY, WITH WALL STREET, TOP
UNIVERSITIES, AND THE AMERICAN
MEDIA, HOLLYWOOD.
WELL, THEIR M.O. IS ALWAYS THE
SAME.
DANGLE PROMISES OF HUGE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT OR PROFIT AS
LONG AS EVERYONE LOOKS THE OTHER
WAY ON THEIR HUMAN HORRENDOUS HU
RECORD.
BY USING THIS APPROACH OF THE
LAST TWO DAYS OR SO, CHINA HAS
GROWN IN WEALTH, THEY’VE GROWN
IN POWER, AND THEY’VE GROWN IN
PRESTIGE ACROSS EVERY SECTOR.
THEY MADE THE CYNICAL
CALCULATION THAT HIGH-POWERED
WESTERNERS WOULD TAKE SHORT-TERM
PAYOFFS IN EXCHANGE FOR FREEDOM
AND INDEPENDENCE.
THEY SACRIFICED THE LATTER.
WELL, THEY WERE RIGHT, SADLY.
AT LEAST UNTIL THEY MET THEIR
MATCH IN DONALD TRUMP.
HIS AMERICA-FIRST APPROACH TO
TRADE PUT CHINA ON THE DEFENSIVE
AND IT FORCED CHINA TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE, MAKING
CONCESSIONS AND EVENTUALLY A
TRADE DEAL.
A TRADE DEAL THAT OBAMA AND BUSH
COULD OR WOULD NEVER MAKE.
THE GLOBALISTS WERE HAPPY WITH
THEIR RELATIONSHIPS WITH JOHN
DURING THOSE 16 YEARS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THOUGH, IS
TRYING TO WALK A FINE LINE.
HE’S NOT AS HARSH ON CHINA AS I
WOULD BE BUT HE HAS A DIFFERENT
JOB.
HE’S TRYING TO BALANCE OUR
ECONOMIC NEEDS, THAT ARE VERY
BIG RIGHT NOW, WITH NATIONAL
SECURITY.
AND LET ME BE CLEAR, NO ONE AND
I MEAN NO ONE HAS DONE MORE TO
STAND UP TO CHINA AND TAKE ON
THE CHALLENGES THAT THEY’VE
POSED THEN DONALD J. TRUMP.
HIS ADMINISTRATION, IT’S FILLED
WITH HARD-CORE CHINA REALISTS.
>> CHINA IS A VERY SERIOUS
THREAT TO THE UNITED STATES,
GEOPOLITICALLY, ECONOMICALLY,
MILITARILY, AND A THREAT TO THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR INSTITUTIONS.
>> ITS ASSESSED OUR
VULNERABILITIES, AND IT’S
DECIDED TO EXPLOIT OUR FREEDOMS
AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OVER US.
SPEAK OUR MESSAGE TO CHINA’S
RULERS IS THIS: THIS PRESIDENT
WILL NOT BACK DOWN.
AT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL NOT
BE SWAYED.
>> Laura: BUT THE PROBLEM IS,
TOO MANY ELITES ARE TOTALLY IN
THE TANK FOR CHINA.
THE WORST OFFENDERS WHEN YOU
THINK OF ALL THE REALLY BAD
OFFENDERS OUT THERE, THE WORST
ARE PERHAPS THE UNIVERSITIES AND
THEIR CONNECTIONS WITH CHINA AND
THUS THE CCP RUN DEEP.
SINCE 2013, CHINA HAS GIVEN A
BILLION DOLLARS TO 115 COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES.
HARVARD WAS THE BIGGEST
RECIPIENT, PULLING A $97 MILLION
BUT THAT IS NOT ALL.
A HUGE NUMBER OF CHINESE
STUDENTS HANDPICKED BY THE CCP
ARE ADMITTED AT UNIVERSITIES
INCLUDING HARVARD.
INCLUDING, BY THE WAY,
PRESIDENT XI’S DAUGHTER, WHO
GRADUATED FROM HARVARD JUST A
FEW YEARS BACK.
HARVARD HAS EVEN SET UP AN
ACADEMIC CENTER IN SHANGHAI AND
ESTABLISHED A HARVARD-CHINA
FUND, WHICH SUPPORTS TEACHING
AND RESEARCH IN CHINA AND ALSO
PROMOTES HARVARD’S PRESENCE IN
CHINA.
CHINA HAS GIVEN HARVARD, AS I
SAID, $93.7 MILLION, 200,070
CHINESE STUDENTS AND SCHOLARS AT
HARVARD.
HARVARD NOW HAS AN ACADEMIC
CENTER IN CHINA.
ALL OF THIS THAT WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT, THIS IS STUNNING,
STUNNING STUFF.
AND BY THE WAY, HARVARD’S
RECRUITMENT OF CHINESE SCHOLARS
AND CHINESE CONNECTION.
MY FAVORITE STORY.
A RENOWNED HARVARD RESEARCHER
WAS BUSTED FOR ALLEGEDLY LYING
ABOUT HIS INVOLVEMENT IN A
CHINESE RECRUITMENT OPERATION.
THE PRC HAD PAID HIM $50,000 A
MONTH PLUS LIVING EXPENSES FOR
HIS WORK AT WUHAN UNIVERSITY OF
TECHNOLOGY.
AND GET THIS, HE RAN HIS OWN
NANO SCIENCE CENTER AT HARVARD.
HE’S A BRAINIAC.
HE RECEIVED $15 MILLION IN
GRANTS FROM -- WAIT FOR IT --
THE NIH.
ALL THE WHILE, HE WAS TAKING BIG
MONEY FROM CHINA TO ALLEGEDLY
HELP THEM RECRUIT TALENT TO THEN
STEAL OUR TRADE SECRETS.
THIS IS HARVARD’S PRESIDENT LAST
MARCH.
>> HARVARD IS AN AMERICAN
UNIVERSITY AS THAT IS A CHINESE
UNIVERSITY.
OUR INSTITUTIONS HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO CONTRIBUTE
POSITIVELY TO OUR OWN SOCIETIES
AND TO THE NATIONAL GOOD.
AS WELL AS TO THE WORLD AT
LARGE.
BUT AS UNIVERSITIES, WHEN YOU
FULFILL THIS CHARGE PRECISELY BY
EMBODYING AND DEFENDING ACADEMIC
VALUES THAT TRANSCEND THE VALUES
OF ANY ONE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: I LOVE THE
SOUNDTRACK, BY THE WAY,
UNDERNEATH THAT.
TRANSCEND THE VALUES OF ANY
NATION.
AS WE SEE IN THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC, BOUNDARIES DO IN FACT
MATTER, AND THE CPC’S VALUES ARE
PRIORITIZED
HARVARD HAS PLANTED THE STUDENTS
AND RESEARCHERS ACROSS AMERICA.
MOST RECENTLY THE UNIVERSITY OF
TEXAS, UCLA, AND THE UNIVERSITY
OF KANSAS.
AND AGAIN, YOU, THE U.S.
TAXPAYERS, ARE FUNDING THIS.
FOR MORE THAN A DECADE I’VE BEEN
WARNING ABOUT THE DAMAGE THIS IS
BEEN DOING TO AMERICA, AND
SENATOR TOM COTTON, HE IS
RIGHTLY OUTRAGED.
>> IT’S UNDERSTANDABLE TO ME
THAT WE HAVE TRAINED SO MANY OF
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY’S
BRIGHTEST MINDS TO GO BACK TO
CHINA TO COMPETE FOR OUR JOBS,
TO TAKE OUR BUSINESS, AND
ULTIMATELY TO STEAL OUR
PROPERTY.
>> Laura: NOW WHAT IS MOST
INSANE ABOUT THIS IS HOW THE
MEDIA HAVE LAPPED UP CHINA
PROPAGANDA.
NOW, POLITICO HAS PRAISED
CHINA’S HANDLING OF THE PANDEMIC
THAT IT CAUSED.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS WORRIED.
IT’S WORRIED ABOUT HOW COVID-19
COULD HURT CHINA.
AND CNN, WELL, IT SHOULD JUST BE
REBRANDED PRC AND THEN.
PRC AND THEN ITS SHAMELESS
PROMOTION OF CHINESE PROPAGANDA.
EVEN WHEN THEY KICK OUT A
PROMINENT JOURNALIST OUR
NEWSPAPERS, EVEN WHEN THEY
IMPRISON A MILLION ETHNIC
MUSLIMS, EVEN WHEN AS WE SAW
THIS PAST MONTH, CHINA RIPS
CROSSES OFF CHURCHES AND OTHER
BUILDINGS, TO THE SICK AND
TWISTED SYSTEM.
IT IS THE SOVIET UNION ON
STEROIDS.
WE DIDN’T DO ALMOST ANYTHING
SIGNIFICANT VIS-A-VIS TRADE WITH
THE SOVIET UNION.
REMEMBER?
WE ALLOWED NO STUDENT TRANSFERS
FROM THE SOVIET UNION.
THOSE SOVIET STUDENTS AT A TOP
UNIVERSITY.
AND THAT WORKED OUT WELL FOR US
IN THE END.
WHY?
BECAUSE REAGAN UNDERSTOOD WE
WEREN’T GOING TO ENRICH THE
USSR, THAT WOULD’VE BEEN
DISASTROUS FOR US.
WE BEAT THEM.
IT WAS PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH.
AND TRUMP HAD TAKEN IMPORTANT
STEPS TO REBALANCING OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA AND THEN
THE CORONAVIRUS HITS, COURTESY
OF CHINA.
OBVIOUSLY CHINA IS HOPING AT
THIS POINT FOR A DEMOCRAT IN THE
OVAL OFFICE.
THAT IS BEYOND OBVIOUS.
AND OF COURSE, WE KNOW WHAT A
BIDEN PRESIDENCY WOULD BE TO THE
PRC.
A GIFT.
>> LET ME BE CLEAR.
I BELIEVED IN 1979 AND SAID SO,
AND I BELIEVE NOW THAT A RISING
CHINA IS A POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT.
NOT ONLY FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CHINA, BUT FOR THE UNITED STATES
AND THE WORLD AS A WHOLE.
>> Laura: AS WE GET CLOSER TO
ELECTION DAY, REMEMBER THIS: AS
MANY ELITESES IN ACADEMIA,
BUSINESS AND THE MEDIA ARE DOING
CHINA’S BIDDING, YOU HAVE A
PRESIDENT WHO HAS ALWAYS SEEN
THEM FOR WHO THEY ARE, COMMUNIST
POWER THAT IS WORKING 24/7 TWO
ECLIPSE US MILITARILY AND
ECONOMICALLY.
IF YOU THINK FREEDOM WILL MARCH
THROUGH BEIJING ANYTIME SOON,
JUST REMEMBER TOURNAMENT SQUARE.
REMEMBER LAST YEAR’S HONG KONG
PROTEST AND REMEMBER CHINA’S
REFUSAL TO REVEAL ALL THAT IT
KNOWS ABOUT THE VIRUS THAT HAS
NOW KILLED MORE THAN 70,000